foreign
[Music]
don't you dare let that little red dog
piss on my walkway again ignore him
Prince he has no idea who's doing that
well it was one of you
get out of here
you cannot use this road without a
permit have a nice day sir you know the
other guys don't do this guys with the
white trucks how come it's always you
brown guys and I don't mean that
racially
I'm sorry to get me earlier the whole
neighborhood has fallen apart these days
[Music]
oh my God give me the keys
hello hello what's your name Otto
Otto o-t-t-o I'm Abby o-t-t-o
got some new neighbors right that weird
husband
I brought you some food okay okay bye
are you always this unfriendly I am not
unfriendly okay you're not every word
you say is like a warm cuddle
[Music]
can you please give me a ride I don't
have a license you don't have a driver's
license how old are you
[Music]
a hybrid
[Music]
how did you get in here
no no no you are not taking over my bed
I was wondering if you could help us out
I'm not sure about this it's gonna be
very fun
how was it you did a good job you should
pat yourself on the back
[Music]
[Music]
to do everything on your own guess what
no one can
run
you want to see a trick yeah if I borrow
a coin what are you doing
it was all the Clown's fault
foreign
[Music]